yesterday we got a new report saying
that the official death toll in Puerto
Rico from Hurricane Maria now stands at
two thousand nine hundred and
seventy-five human lives American
citizens because let's not forget Puerto
Ricans are American citizens that is a
u.s. territory it should be a US state
it should be afforded every protection
that every other state and this nation
gets yet for some reason we are not
allowing that to happen even though
Puerto Ricans have voted overwhelmingly
time and time again to officially become
a state here in the United States the
original death toll from the federal
government was I think 64 they said
sixty four people died in Hurricane
Maria and now it turns out that no fewer
than two thousand nine hundred and
seventy five people died which is a four
thousand five hundred percent increase
in the official death toll from this
disaster so far the administration has
been silent nothing not a word not a
peep we're talking about a natural
disaster that claimed just as many
American lives almost as many American
lives I should say as the 9/11 attacks
almost three thousand people died on
that island in this storm
one storm so now we know that that is
what the official death toll is going
with other reports have said the number
could actually be closer to five
thousand nonetheless we're dealing with
this two thousand nine hundred and
seventy-five number at this point how
did we get there well let's start with
one of the most obvious but it's not one
that gets much play you had credit
agencies bond agencies major banks here
in the United States that basically
screwed over Puerto Rico for years there
is massive ongoing litigation over what
those big banks did
essentially stealing money that Puerto
Rican citizens had put into bonds there
on the island you know investing in
their own government so to speak with
these bonds but the big banks ripped
them off stole the money left them with
nothing and left Puerto Rico with
nothing to help build up their
infrastructure that's one of the reasons
there was so much damage from it there
was no money the money was all with the
big banks who swindled them if you
haven't had the opportunity to look at
some of the litigations and some of the
allegations that have come out of that I
do suggest you take the time to look
into it a little bit sant ender it's one
of the banks involved in this it's
absolutely disgusting what they did to
the people there second we have the
pitiful response from FEMA when you look
at Hurricane Harvey it took less than I
think four to six days and you had 73
different helicopters coming in and out
with supplies rescuing people doing
things like that at Puerto Rico it took
several weeks before we had helicopters
down there offering aid evacuating
people bringing supplies weeks to get
there to do this it's almost like
everybody forgot Puerto Rico existed or
more importantly forgot that they were
in American citizens or more importantly
than that forgot that they were human
beings because everybody likes to say
like let's not forget they're American
citizens we got to take care of them yes
that's true
but they're also human beings so we
should take care of them nationality
doesn't matter race doesn't matter
language doesn't matter
human beings are suffering we should
help them that's a message that I think
too few people in this country
especially those on the right seem to
understand but aside from just saying
well people are suffering we should help
them yes as a country we had a
responsibility a legal obligation to go
and help them FEMA dropped the ball here
FEMA was late getting down there they
were horrible and getting out supplies
they
how much they needed to help the people
on the island and this is actually from
an internal female report by the way
this isn't just an assessment I'm giving
FEMA admitted this they said there were
about five thousand employees short to
even be able to properly respond to last
year's hurricane season they also admit
that they've been grossly underfunded
thanks to Republican budget cuts and
that's what happens when Republicans go
out there and talk about we got to
shrink the government we got to cut
their budgets they're bloated they're
overgrown this is what you get you get a
situation like Puerto Rico where our
agencies that are tasked with going down
there and helping people and saving
people and making sure everything is
okay and put back together they can't do
their jobs because they don't have the
funding to do it as a federal agency
you also had National Guard down there
and as I mentioned on yesterday's
program they left tractor-trailer
trailers full of supplies sitting on the
islands election headquarters in their
parking lot as they just left them New
York Times report from a week or two ago
said that these supplies were left in
there
nobody was told what to do nobody was
told how to distribute so nobody
distributed him before they left the
National Guard were the ones handing
this stuff out but when it was time to
pack up and leave they didn't bother to
tell anybody what to do with it so we
just sat there and it rotted in those
trailers there's plenty of blame to go
around but at the end of the day when
nearly 3,000 American citizens died on
your watch this whole atrocity falls at
the feet of the President of the United
States we all remember the massive
backlash across the country to George
Bush's pitiful response to Hurricane
Katrina and yet there is almost complete
silence coming from the public demanding
some kind of accountability for Trump's
dismal response to Puerto Rico not that
we would get anything from him I mean
let's be honest this man knows exactly
what he did
did it on purpose he did it because he
doesn't care